the Joe Rogan experience is there anyone
else doing this so there are many
organizations working on the on the
prevention side right so educating
people think about policies those kind
of things which is very important I
think
but yeah unfortunately we're the only
ones that sort of do the the hard
technology side of it and yeah I wish
you know more people would do it if
somebody else would clean the ocean
that'd be fine with us as well but until
somebody else does it yeah we're kind of
the ones that have to do that's so
fascinating to me that are the seven
billion people on the planet sometimes
it really does just take one person to
act one person do something about
something that I mean I'm aware of many
people aware of many people listening
have heard about this and and it's sort
of one of those things that's in the
back of your mind that doesn't affect
you on a daily basis so you say well
that's a tragedy that's a terrible thing
but it's not my problem I have my own
problems but you this one person decided
to do something about it the fact that
you did when you were 16 is so
fascinating to me and someone has to do
it right but isn't that weird
someone has to but nobody was doing [ __ ]
until you came yeah very interesting
yeah yeah it's sometimes wonder yeah
sometimes people ask me like well why
why do you do it and like yes my answer
would be like why not yeah why isn't
everyone doing this my one thing that I
was thinking was and this is my same
feeling about pollution air pollution is
that once they figured out a way to use
whatever is in the particulate sand air
pollution as a resource sure and make it
valuable then people are going to be
running to extract it out of the skies
and I felt the same way about the
Pacific Garbage Patch and all the other
ocean currents where they have this this
issue so what is it the currents bring
everything together collectively into
one area just because of the way the
ocean moves exactly yeah so you have
these sort of current at the equator and
then you have these boundary currents
and it sort of acts like the
yeah like the the sinking your bathtub
right so it's sort of where all the
plastic once again now is it possible to
take that stuff all of that Pacific all
those disgusting particles and use it
for something yeah I mean sure actually
have few examples with me in my bag but
it's not here right now no grab it do
you wanna grab it no doing a bit I can
describe it okay it's a podcast anyways
so so what we do is we take the plastic
out and we recycle that we've developed
a process for this and we can turn it
into new products so actually the the
pair of sunglasses that finally be able
to wear after a dreaded Northern
European winter they we already made
that out of plastic that we took out of
the Great Pacific Garbage Patch so
you're wearing sunglasses that are
recycled from the ocean exactly and the
idea is that we can do anything with
this right so you can imagine sort of
the part of your next car or your chair
or whatever you can make that out of
ocean plastic and what we think is that
the material itself isn't valuable
enough but it's really the story behind
it so the fact that you can say well
it's made out of the Great Pacific
Garbage Patch which we think will add
value so it's like the difference
between a normal pebble and and the
piece of the Berlin wall it's right one
is worth [ __ ] and the other is worth
something alright so that's what we kind
of want to use as a way to to then be
able to fund the the operations of the
cleaner I think that's a fantastic idea
and I think that'll be a huge value for
people I mean I think people really want
to buy something that they know is
recycled out of something that was
choking fish and birds to death yeah and
not only that but Dida's is turning
plastic from the ocean into $200 shoes
the sportswear maker is teaming up with
something to sell three new shoes made
with plastic pulled from the ocean wow
that's awesome the kind of stuff you can
do so I mean this is also adidas
actually didn't use a plastic from the
ocean they I think they just said that
for for marketing reasons they then make
that from plastic that was sort of they
call it ocean bound so oh those lie
[ __ ] god damn it
they got him yeah that's [ __ ] so
it's on the way to the ocean yeah which
I guess is any could be anything like it
was like we were gonna throw it out
because I make sneakers right that's
horrible I mean still
[Laughter]
they're very cool I like I like them and
I like the the people that work on it
that's everything but that's a lie yeah
well yeah a white like a little bit yeah
but yeah so I mean the composition of
the plastic that we'll be pulling out of
the ocean is it's pretty unique it's
it's quite degraded because of the
decades of UV light hitting it so so we
really had to develop a new process to
to do this so probably maybe in a year
or so we'll be actually able to launch
the first line of products made out of
sort of real the real deal the plastic
actually coming out of the ocean that's
excellent so you're gonna sell like raw
plastic and is there an issue of who
owns the plastic I mean even cuz it cuz
is in the Commons of the the ocean in
international waters I think it'd be
hilarious if somebody would sort of
raise their hand is there others my
pleasure guys put it in there we have
another kind of legal issue yeah but if
it comes a resource like oil yeah yeah I
think there's some there's like this
these Salvage laws that say if if you
sort of salvage something and brought
the international options you can
actually keep it so that doesn't appear
to be an issue but yeah definitely it
will be yeah sort of closing the circle
will be a fun project yeah I mean it
sounds it sounds like an amazing thing
and I guarantee people would be very
very interested to buy things that they
know were made out of something that was
really a horrible side effect of
civilization yeah I think if you have
the choice between a normal mother is
let's use this sunglass example you know
a normal pair or a pair coming out of
the ocean I think 9 out of 10 people
would choose that oh for sure I mean I
think it would be giant for companies to
to advertise that we only use a hundred
percent recycled from the ocean plastic
that would be gigantic
[Applause]